so willkommen zu der Hyundai zu Mineral
Reportage Leben mit dem Wolf wo ganz
ganz viel Kommentar ausgelöst hat und
wir werden jetzt das Bar für deine
diskutieren
und am Schluss vor der Reportage stehen
noch später im q&ay mit dem expert von
herderschutzhund wo beim plattenhof
schafft das ist so in Graubünden als
wichtigsten Kompetenzzentrum wenn es um
landwirtschaftsvorgegossen
der hätte ganz viele Fragen an die
wieso hast du überhaupt scharf Gott zum
um Milch und Fleisch wieso
also ihr habt einfach will ich sie gerne
haben oder natürlich
geht das Produkt aus denen scharf also
und was essen du alles davon
und werden zu Lammfleisch verarbeitet
und Fell werden auch zu lammfällen
verarbeitet gerbt genau und der
Teilnehmer werden auch LEBIG an andere
Betrieb verkauft als Zuchttier oder
Hobby Tier genau natürlich
das alles für die
nein für mich jetzt nicht will ich nicht
den Betrieb bin wo auf das ausgeleitet
ist oder mir geht's nicht darum zum
rentieren
und dass ich ja völlig in der Artikel
die trägen sich selber finanziell
gesehen also
wieso gibt nur die Schafe auf die Alb wo
die Gefahr größer ist dass sie gerissen
werden wie wieso gehst du die nicht oft
Alp so macht man das
ja zum einen gut oder also Ciao Fendt
auch wenn man sie im Frühling und im
Herbst doch immer noch viel wohler denn
wieder bildet über der Sommer und wir
brauchen sie als Witterungsschutz aber
jetzt war das vor dem Regen und die
hätten einfach vieles warm da tun ah
wirklich ja nicht gut wenn man die 30
Grad da auf einer 600 Meter über
Mehrheit ich meine das ist nicht ideal
der körend entberger und auch möglichst
höher und können natürlich auch an Ort
wo man mit Kühe gar nicht könnte weiter
oder
sorry betreffend
mit der Brigitte Wolf heißt sie wissen
[Musik]
wohnt im Kanton Wallis politisierte da
wieder grüner
Biologin und haben sie eher so die
biologische Frage gefragt und ein fragte
die Sound all begangen
Rafael Allmann schreibt es auf die Alp
gehen hat Tradition und ist wichtig weil
die Alpen so nicht einwachsen was ist
denn negativ daran wenn die Alpen
einwachsen
mal vor es ist nur recht spannend also
man muss unterscheiden von welchen Alpen
man spricht ob eine Beweidung positiv
oder negativ ist hängt stark von der
natürlichen Vegetation ab die Beweidung
kann zum Beispiel verhindern dass ein
ein Gebiet nur noch erlenstauden oder
Wacholder Büsche wachsen es gibt aber
auch Gebiete in hohen Lagen wo die
Beweidung zu einem Verlust von seltenen
Alpenpflanzen führt Schafe die sich frei
bewegen können haben die Gewohnheit den
besten Kräutern in den höchsten Lagern
nachzugehen das kann zu einer
Übernutzung der alpinen Rasen und zu
Erosion führen zudem können Schafe und
Ziegen in diesem Gebieten eine
Konkurrenz für Games und Steinböcke sein
wichtig ist bei der Beweidung deshalb
auch ohne Wortes Präsenz dass die dass
die Haustiere behärtet und geführt
werden und dass diejenige Gebiete
beweidet werden wo es gut ist für die
Biodiversität also Thema fassen
Gott betreffend Entschädigung also wenn
es dir auf der Alb gerissen wird und man
kann bewiesen dass es vom Wolf gesehen
weil du nicht und das
herderschutzmaßnahmen
vom Bund und Kanton zerma das ist in der
Höhe vom Marktwert aber hey was kostet
überhaupt so schön
zu den Entschädigungen kann ich jetzt
nicht so viel zeigen wenn ihr Islam
gongo direkt verkaufe im Herbst
überkommission zwischen 220 und 260
Franken für das Land okay also das
schaut bei der Marktwert wurde
Reportage voll nicht besprochen
ja und Dir wo man den Sinn und sinnlos
schlachtend oder ich aus Thema in meiner
Dirt zum Teil sterben so hat einfach im
Herbst wenn es Metzger werden in einer
Jahr den sterben sie auch
was ich das Problem was ist Problem
man kann das so gesehen aber
der Tod im Schlachthof wenn ich direkt
Vermarktung
erstens werdens verwertet oder für der
menschliche Konsum da haben wir
natürlich darüber streiten ob man das
Fleisch essen will oder nicht
die Leute war bei mir Fleisch kaufen der
kaufen kein Australien wo einmal quer
und Welt ist transportiert worden
sondern es ist regional und
dahergestellt schafft auch Arbeitsplatz
und ich denke wir verdient
ob es im ich sag mal in der vertrautung
im Normalfall fahren wir auf die nächste
weit oder in der Stall oder Sie stiegend
gerne
und dann werden zum Schlachthof
ausgeladen und ich laufe mit jedem
einzelnen Tier innerhalb und den Toten
Metzger das Schießen und das ist vor
wenigen Sekunden von der Betäubung
geflötet werden natürlich ist das nicht
schön mit dem trotzdem ein Unterschied
als wenn mehrere Wölfe
apropos
so viele Schafe aufs Maul reißen aber
das haben unsere Biologin geschickt
gefragt also das Hauptproblem ist dass
der Wolf auf eine unnatürliche Situation
trifft normalerweise wenn es zum
Beispiel Hirsche Jagd erwischt es
höchstens ein Tier auf das schwächste
des Rudels die anderen Tiere sind längst
weg bei schaffen ist das anders sie
können entweder nicht fliehen weil sie
im Zaun eingesperrt sind oder fliehe
nicht weil sie ihr natürliches Verhalten
verlernt haben und zusammenleiben wollen
nachdem der Wolf einschlaf getötet hat
stehen und rennen die anderen immer noch
umher also habt ihr sagt ihm sein
Instinkt das ermöglicht viele Tiere
töten soll dasselbe Phänomen kann man
beobachten wenn ein Fuchs in ein
Hühnerstall eindringt was auch noch
spannend ist
durchgesetzte Funktion im Ökosystem also
das ist Auftrag
was bringt der Wolf für Ökosystem also
Raubtier an der Spitze der Nahrungskette
hat der Wolf natürlich einen Einfluss
auf seine Beutetiere einerseits weil die
Tiere ja Achtung frisst andererseits hat
er einen Einfluss auf das Verhalten der
Beutetiere in wolfsgebieten ist die
Raumnutzung der Huftiere anders als in
Gebieten ohne Wolf zum Beispiel gibt es
im Waldgebieten weniger grosse
Ansammlungen von Hirschen zudem kann ein
Hirsch nicht jeden Abend am gleichen Ort
vom Wald auf die Wiese fressen kommen
das Lernen die Wölfe schnell das
wiederum hat den Einfluss auf die
Vegetation man geht heute zum Beispiel
davon aus dass Wölfe einen positiven
Einfluss auf den Wald haben weil die
jungen Bäume in wolfsgebieten weniger
verbissen werden
also so viel zu der Aufgabe in deren
biodiverse Rat vom Wolf und irgendwo
dazwischen
finden und das ist schon auch noch
wichtig zum berücksichtigen denke ich
mir alle anderen geschützten
zum Thema herderschutz zum Beispiel Weg
der Hund
so ich bin jetzt da zum Malans im Kanton
Graubünden ganz viel ZuschauerInnen
gehört sie miteinander
und das da ist der Jan Bohne du bist
Experte
schutzhüter
und jetzt ist der Kommentare wieso tut
man die Herde auf der alten einfach mit
Hund schützen und das ist ja bis wo
heutzutage schon passiert wie
funktioniert das mit deiner herderschutz
auf der Alpen aber auf Licht im talduna
in Kanton Graubünden also für uns ist
das relativ neues gibt es erst seit 20
Jahren und entsprechend
es ist so es braucht sicher das
bezüglich zwischen dem Nutztier und dem
Hund es braucht bezüglich zwischen dem
Mensch und einem Hund es ist sehr
komplexeamt fahren wir auch wirklich gut
zwei drei Jahren
wie viel Hühnen sind denn auf so einer
typischen Alb also keine typische Alb
zum Beispiel hätte vielleicht
900.000.500 bis sogar
es ist so meridianische Rudel und im
Fall von Rudel heißt das dass man eine
permanente Druck von einer großen Team
hat gegenüber also teamworld
da sind dann ist das schnell gemacht
oder autopografie jede Alpen
zum Teil ist es
also
pauschale Antwort so viel Chef so viel
Höhen viele
alpenschutzmaßnahmen für die Alpen aber
trotzdem
wie viel das passiert ist man tünnen
schlechter Job sind es wenig hündumenant
wenn die einfach keine Chance oder also
was ist los also es ist mir gesagt sehr
sehr anspruchsvoll das ist wie eine
komplexes Schiff wo man auf mehr
versucht in die richtig richtig stören
superhunde Teams auf gut geführten Alpen
wo stark unter Druck sind weil es
erfahrungswolf die im Gegenüber ist wo
über Jahre erfolgska hat an einzelnen
Tiere und die sind parat beide
Mannschaften sind parat und trotzdem sie
schwimmen
und das spielt wirklich auch aus extrem
schwierig und unmöglich wirklich ohne
Schaden
was machst du da
mit Hund jetzt eh nicht so
die beste Kollege bin und das hätte man
ja schon gehört dass Herren
Auftrag ja
das ist da die Ressourcen zwarer und
alles fremder wird prüft und
entsprechend
kritisch ist die Prüfung wenn man da
einfach sage
unverhäufen auch ohne Respekt
tri-trampelt wenn man das ein bisschen
impulsiv macht denn noch erkennen die
Hündinnen
und das ist wahnsinnig unangenehm und
wenn man sie wenn man den auch noch
Quatsch macht und einfach fuchteln und
Schmerzen und irgendwie nervös du dann
hätten wir bald ein bisschen irgendwo
oder es ist wirklich so dass die Höhen
die ihre Arbeit Leistung auf 39
andere sieht dann das gefällt mir jetzt
die Steuer bewiesen
die Hunde halten da also
theaterschutzhunde Halter sind
wahnsinnig bemüht und auch kalt oder
Kontakt zu Zweibeiner im Werdegang für
den Hund immer wieder wir haben es jetzt
auch machen genau positiv positiv
positiv
danke vielmal das ist schon alles das
ist ja alles vor der q&d ja falls du die
Reportage noch nicht gesehen
auf der Seite verlinkt und
ja
bis zum nächsten Mal